[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 15 avril bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle page et cette
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 a tout de suite les titres de
ce 7 8 journal elle était à la tête de
la municipalité depuis novembre 2016
marie-christine le tarnec et démissionne
de son mandat de maire l'élu l'a fait
savoir aujourd'hui dans une lettre
adressée aux habitants
une décision motivée pour des raisons de
santé le meeting de benoît hamon
vendredi attrape la tête de liste aux
européennes et fondateur de génération
point s est revenu dans la ville pour la
première fois depuis la campagne des
législatives en 2010 sept territoires où
il a été député mais aussi conseiller
municipal 400 personnes ont assisté à la
réunion
et puis le château de versailles
accueille aujourd'hui la première
édition de cet événement le trianon
start up a réuni de grands groupes
français et entreprises russes
un rendez vous sous l'égide du dialogue
de trianon forum lancé par emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine pour
intensifier les échanges entre les deux
pays et nous parlerons un tout à l'heure
en plateau des 70 ans de la ligue contre
le cancer des yvelines présentation à
suivre aussi de la nature box lancée par
l' agence des espaces verts d'île de
france
elle nous l'avons donc appris
aujourd'hui marie christine le tarnec à
démissionne de son mandat de maire à
guyancourt l'élu siège est à la tête du
conseil municipal est depuis novembre
2016 suite à la démission à l'époque de
l'édile en place françois de ligné il
s'agissait de son premier mandat et
guyancourt
une décision prise en raison des soucis
de santé dans une lettre adressée aux
habitants elle s'explique cela me semble
incompatible avec l'exercice du mandat
de maire tel que je le conçois fin de
citation elle dit terminé son engagement
d'élu avec beaucoup de tristesse
engagement assuré avec grands honneurs
en attendant l'élection au sein du
conseil municipal d'un nouveau maire
c'est le premier adjoint de guyancourt
françois morton qui assure l'intérim
marie-christine le tarnec
elle reste tout de même conseillère
municipale et conserve pour le moment sa
vice-présidence à l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
politique toujours avec le retour de
benoît hamon à trappes après les
législatives en 2010 est celle ec les
européennes qui donne l'occasion à
l'ancien élu municipal et député de
revenir dans
ville yvelinoise un meeting vendredi et
du porte à porte en tant que tête de
liste de son mouvement pour le scrutin
génération point s est le reportage de
nicolas dandois revenir au contact des
trappistes pour les informer des
élections européennes le 26 mai prochain
le principe de ce porte à porte organisé
par benoît hamon et son mouvement
génération point est ce un retour sur
ses anciennes terres lui le député de la
11e circonscription des yvelines entre
2012 et 2017
mais j'ai toujours eu une bonne relation
avec la plupart des habitants de cette
ville c'est c'est on a une énorme police
latif j'ai perdu au tennis hâtives mais
à trappes j'étais largement en tête sur
la ville pas sur la circonscription dont
il ya toujours une relation un peu assez
forte avec les habitants de cette ville
à ses côtés notamment des élus locaux à
lire ab adjoint chargé des sports sur la
commune de trappes et bertrand guillon
maire de magny les hameaux
[Musique]
j'accompagne benoît hamon puisque je
crois foncièrement à une europe qui soit
plus sociale qui soit plus juste pour
les gens qui assurent la liberté des
citoyennes et des citoyens
après le porte-à-porte place au meeting
près de 400 personnes présentes dans la
salle jean baptiste clément
la plupart des militants de la première
heure ces propositions de gauche je le
soutiens depuis le début ce sont des
valeurs de gauche
voilà donc je soutiens son programme
font effectivement whitney pour l'europe
on est pour la gauche on est pour le
l'écologie sociale
benoît hamon est accompagné de plusieurs
candidats de la liste génération point s
notamment guillaume balas et salah
amokrane ils défendent une europe
sociale et écologiste
le smic européen avec un smic à 60% du
salaire moyen
donc avec un objectif de 1350 euros nets
c'est parfaitement possible et l'europe
peut y contribuer de manière très
concrète en faveur d'un printemps
européen benoît hamon compte soutenir
l'ex ministre des finances grec qui a
nice varoufakis pour prendre la tête de
la commission européenne et ce lundi
soir c'est la tête de liste les
républicains pour les européennes
françois xavier et bellamy qui tiendra
une réunion à bois d'arcy
c'est une réponse à la recrudescence des
violences
les établissements franciliens des
brigades régionales de sécurité vont
être déployés dans les lycées de la
région annoncent ce lundi matin de la
présidente de l' île de france valérie
pécresse 15 agents seront recrutés sont
répartis en trois zones en trois groupes
elle l'un d'eux basé à argenteuil dans
le val d'oise que tu intervenir
également dans les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine sur demande des
établissements vendredi soir près de 300
enseignants se sont réunis à versailles
à l'appel de quatre syndicats ils ont
profité du déplacement du ministre jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale est venu assister à un débat à
l'université interâges pour faire
entendre leur mécontentement colère
notamment contre le projet de loi pour
une école de la confiance qui prévoit
l'instruction obligatoire dès trois ans
et le regroupement des écoles et collège
les parents d'élèves se sont joints
également à la manifestation ce matin à
versailles aussi top départ de la
première rencontre entre grands groupes
français et entreprises russes le
trianon start up se dérouler au château
de versailles
manon va raddho a suivi cette journée de
relations franco-russes au château de
versailles ce lundi s'est déroulée la
première édition en france du trianon
start-up une première dans le cadre du
dialogue de trianon dont l'objectif est
d'intensifier les échanges entre les
sociétés civiles des deux pays dans une
grande variété de domaines initiative
lancée par les président emmanuel macron
et vladimir poutine en mai 2010 est il
avait lancé l'idée que les sociétés
civiles des deux pays se rencontrent et
on nous a demandé donc avec un conseil
de coordination moitié français moitié
russe 15 15
allez-y
on vous donne le coup d'envoi et trouver
des formules originales pour permettre
des rencontres la journée trianon
start-up revisite le concept du forum
travailler ensemble 30 start-up russes
ont fait le déplacement
en face de ces jeunes pousses une
quinzaine d'entreprises françaises
étaient présents tels que thales air
france total ou encore air liquide
il se rend compte pour desserrer de
courte entrevue qui a pas de différence
entre les grands groupes et les startups
tout le monde change tout le monde
tourne et se rencontrent donc pendant 20
minutes trois minutes avant la fin des
rendez-vous on sonne une première fois
les cloches et apprend les ressorts une
deuxième fois elle la deuxième fois
c'est le moment où il faut changer de
table et se diriger vers le rendez-vous
sûr on espère c'est évidemment faire des
rencontres comme d'habitude des
rencontres de qualité et qui se suivront
par des études d'opportunité et pourquoi
pas des partenariats fructueux pour nous
deux à la fin de cette journée les
participants ont pu identifier un
partenaire ou un projet concret afin
d'amorcer rapidement une relation
d'affaires linverse va se produire c'est
à dire que les startups françaises iront
alors rencontrer les grandes entreprises
russes et c'est exactement la vocation
d'un dialogue
à noter donc dans les agendas la
prochaine rencontre entre les deux pays
est fixé pour l'automne à moscou une
page santé dans ce journal avec cet
anniversaire des plus importants le
comité des yvelines de la ligue contre
le cancer à 70 ans l'anniversaire a été
célébré à lors de son assemblée générale
la semaine dernière au lycée
d'hôtellerie et de tourisme de
guyancourt pour en parler maurice brun
bonsoir bonsoir êtes le président du
comité des yvelines de la ligue contre
le cancer alors 70 ans pour le comité ce
que c'est un anniversaire important pôle
qualité tous les anniversaires sont
importants viennent sans nom vient de
fêter les dernières le centenaire du de
la ligue donc libre nationale n'avait
bien le droit nous même de fêter nos 70
ans
non c'est anecdotique la natte
simplement tout a beaucoup évolué depuis
la création bien évidemment pourquoi
parce que à l'époque de la création on
avait le
des personnalités qui était un type au à
la confluence du monde politique du
monde de la santé qui ont créé des
choses par exemple le premier centre
pour les cancéreux a été créé avec
veillée on disait les cancéreux l'époque
et c'est un établissement ses deux
premiers du genre
puis ensuite effectivement ça s'est
multiplié enfin dans les yvelines
quelques hôpitaux qui sont trop occupés
de cancer à ce moment la deuxième phase
de notre action c'est est de doter ses
essais ses services de matériel
spécifique
maintenant c'était une deuxième action
qui s'est fait dans les années 60 70 80
et puis la troisième action quand une
fac cesser ses services ont été équipés
la troisième action citi se préoccuper
du dépistage troisième volet de notre
action donc effectivement
progressivement dans les années 90 début
des années 2000
là le comité des yvelines a lui-même
véritablement investis dans les dents
dans la demie l'association du dépistage
de masse dans les yvelines
donc on va dire trois grandes phases
finales mentions doivent retenir non
historique chez les 70 ans du comité de
ville alors qu'on soit que fictivement
ça c'est à l'époque ancienne l'époque un
petit peu héroïque veut dire maintenant
shaq dans le système de chant de santé
tous ces établissements ont leur place
donc on ne se substitue plus évidemment
aux autres aux autres établissements et
donc il nous faut trouver notre mode de
fonctionnement normal courant alors
c'était le déploiement notamment dans
les années 2000 déploiement de toutes
nos soit le support dont tous les
dispositifs qu'on ma disposition donc
des des personnes touchées par le cancer
et on va parler de résurrection dans un
instant on pense forcément un rôle
important dans un contexte où le cancer
n'a jamais été aussi présent plus de
quatre cent mille cas qui sont détectés
chaque année en france c'est un chiffre
un chiffre par nous qui est en
augmentation
perpétuant absolument alors il ya deux
facteurs bien évidemment il ya une
petite augmentation de la population
mais aussi un vieillissement de celle ci
est donc effectivement naturellement et
pour dire aux jeunes effectivement que
le cancer
ce n'est pas en voie de disparition
c'est en augmentation on en voit de plus
en plus de jeunes donc c'est assez
l'idée que quand j'avais moi-même l'âge
de 2 ans occupe à qui je parlais
honduran bas dans 30 ans dans 40 ans
concernant par la rue ballons non c'est
toujours c'est toujours moi c'est
toujours d'actualité un chiffre en
augmentation alors que
en % des cas de cancer sont en tout cas
évitables absolument tout à fait alors
les domaines dans lequel on peut agir
bien évidemment tout le monde les
connaît
c'est en promulguée l'alcool et le tabac
ça on en reparle plus parce que c'est
tellement c'est courant mais il ya aussi
les dépistages les dépistages qui sont
en place qui sont effectivement des ddd
possibilité donnée à des tranches d'âge
de deux personnes d'éviter d'avoir
inconscient tout au moins de le dépister
plus rapidement donc d'avoir une murs
certitude d'être guéri et bien
malheureusement ces dépistages là encore
il ya encore beaucoup de travail puisque
le dépistage du cancer du sein c'est
encore suédois à 50% mais le dépistage
colorectal c'est un mois à peine 30 % de
gens qui n'ont encore en retard sur ce
groupe il ya un gros gros gain a encore
à obtenir deux d'un très tendue de la
sensibilisation peut être à faire sur le
dépistage financier notre travail
principal 10 alors l'assemblée générale
ça a été aussi l'occasion pour vous de
faire le bilan de l'année 2010 8 des
actions menées par le par la ligue
contre le cancer des yvelines quel type
d'action pu être déployé quel bilan
finalement vous tirez sur cette année
2018 alors d'un côté il ya le bilan
disons d action nationale c'est à dire
qu'effectivement si elle centenaire de
la ligue dont la partie p évidemment au
niveau local à cet anniversaire
il ya un deuxième traque très très
important point c'était lactation des
états généraux de la prévention du
cancer qui ont qui ont vu la leur
résolution en novembre dernier et sur
lequel nous allons désormais travailler
au niveau local pour la mise en place de
beaucoup d'actions qui ont été mon misa
mise à jour lors de ces discussions qui
ont duré pendant plusieurs trimestres et
c'est quoi les types d'action vous met
en place et du dea de la sensibilisation
du dépistage il ya énormément de
d'action dessins de sensibilisation du
public énormément au sidaction dans le
domaine scolaire
c'est de fait de nous avons nous avons
des gens qui à taïwan chez nous dans 240
écoles tous les ans dans les yvelines et
vous disiez la sensibilisation des
jeunes c'est un axe très important mais
on peut passer encore un cap en faisant
en sorte que l'éducation à la science de
vivant si j'ose dire et de la terre tel
qu'il est actuellement saignée dans
l'éducation nationale puisse passer à
l'éducation à la santé donc autrement
dit travailler avec l'éducation
nationale pour aller vers désormais de
nouveaux concepts de nouveaux programmes
qui permettrait ce moment là de passer à
une véritable éducation la santé donc ça
c'est l'un des axes de travail pour 2019
si le principal oui de l'accompagnement
des malades aussi d'envoi
l'accompagnement du malade bien
évidemment il continue il aucune fait qu
augmenter puisque de toute façon nous
faisons que multiplier les actions de
soins de support con qu'on fait qu'on
fait en sorte de décès de répandre de
manière à peu près égalitaire sur
l'ensemble du département
donc ça c'est très important et puis
évidemment toutes les autres actions
qu'on a de sensibilisation du public de
l'entreprise
et puis deux autres axes qu'on le gond
qu'on a commencé ses rues ses rideaux
lien avec l'hôpital combat qui s'est un
peu distendues de l'année et puis touché
les municipalités essayer de travailler
en collaboration avec les municipalités
pour avoir effectivement le fait que la
lutte contre le cancer devient un
partenaire un peu privilégié à la fois
des hôpitaux est à la fois des
municipalités davantage de travail avec
l'enseignement de des liens renforcés
avec les hôpitaux et les municipalités
70 ans qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
aux comités des yvelines de la ligue
contre le cancer à leur anniversaire
c'est la dernière question j'allais le
dire effectivement beaucoup de bénévoles
supplémentaires qui nous permettront de
mettre en place beaucoup d'action et
puis vertement ce qu'il y ait moins de
gens touchés par le cancer organise une
crise des vocations sur les bénévoles
vous avez du mal à attirer les jeunes
bénévoles à renouveler peut-être les
effets on a on a on a eu un creux ces
dix dernières années et là on repart
nettement depuis deux trois ans on a
effectivement un effectif un peu plus
importants et pour aider la ligue contre
le cancer des yvelines rejoindre
peut-être les effectifs de bénévoles
rendez vous sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
maurice brun d'être passé sur ce plateau
président du comité des yvelines coupe
de la ligue contre le cancer
merci bien
ce reportage à présent depuis septembre
le club de bowling de plaisir invite les
résidents du centre hospitalier de la
ville à investir les pistes il accueille
tous les handicaps lors d'ateliers
hebdomadaires un tournoi était même
organisée contre des membres de
l'association et marylène iapichino et
alexis meilhan à la cab all in de mort
par pierrette s'entraîne avec le bouling
club de plaisir pierrette et
pensionnaire au centre hospitalier de
plaisir comme elle des résidents au
handicap différents viennent tous les
mercredis lancer les boules de bowling
c'est très important pour eux ça leur
permet de se tourner vers l'extérieur et
ils aiment avoir une certaine activité
le bouling club de plaisir reçoit des
subventions de sa commune de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et du comité départemental des
yvelines pour permettre ce partenariat
avec le centre hospitalier
les ateliers ont lieu depuis 2018 ce
jour là il s'agit même d'un tournoi pour
jouer avec qui a réglé groupe avec les
grands pas et copines
[Musique]
chaque résident est accompagnée encadré
par un membre du club ils sont quatre à
faire tomber des quilles chaque semaine
ça permet de mettre ces personnes
qui souffrent de handicap dans un
environnement normal
l'association recherche d'autres
subventions vous faire perdurer son
action une manière de faire tomber une
préjugés sur le handicap environnement
une opération nettoyage de printemps
sous tension ce week-end à st rémy
l'honorer en cause une décharge au coeur
de la forêt découverte le mois dernier
par les matchs marcheurs cueilleurs
l'association la qualifie de sauvages
pour la municipalité il s'agit d'un lieu
de stockage temporaire le reportage de
michael ennemis doré de wilfrid riche is
une opération nettoyage de printemps
sous tension ce week end à saint émile
honoré en cause une décharge au coeur de
la forêt découverte le mois dernier par
l'association environnementale les
marcheurs cueilleurs qui la qualifie de
sauvages pour la municipalité il s'agit
d'un lieu de stockage temporaire
on voudrait juste que ce terrain soit
nettoyé que des analyses soient faites
pour savoir s'il ya bien s il ya bien
pollution du sol ou pas ou du sous sol
sachant qu'une rivière coule juste en
contrebas avec depuis un mois on essaie
de voir être là mais avec la mer en
place avec la mairie tout simplement
pour essayer de régler ce problème
trouver les solutions en commun nous lui
tendons la main on est prêt à lui
apporter notre aide et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui à la refuse ça n'est pas une
déchetterie sauval j'insiste sur ce
point c'est un terrain communal privée
fermée et interdite au public un petit
village rural n'a pas les moyens dès
qu'ils amassent un matelas d'aller l'a
mené jusqu'à la déchetterie et donc il
stocke les déchets ramassés au quotidien
sur ce terrain fermé au public j'insiste
est régulièrement
voilà ces déchets sont rapatriés vers la
décharge et la maire de la commune de
s'interroger sur les motivations de
l'association fondée en septembre
dernier ou sont carrément des élections
municipales il ya beaucoup de vocations
qui naissent à un an des élections
municipales
reste que l'association estime avoir vu
des déchets présents depuis plusieurs
mois photo à l'appui voilà on voit que
là ça quand même je pense plusieurs mois
voire plusieurs années déjà
voilà par exemple qu'on voit ce tas de
produits toxiques faut savoir qu'à
l'intérieur c'est de la haine la cie de
la peinture synthétique etc voilà quand
on s'approche et qu'on déterre un petit
peu parce que là on avait enlevé un
petit peu la terre basque est en dessous
l'accès à ce site n'a pas été possible
lors de l'opération de ce week end
l'association a déjà affirmé dans un
courrier adressé au maire et au préfet
utiliser toutes les voies légales pour
le faire disparaître
à quelques jours des vacances de
printemps vous êtes peut-être à la
recherche d'idées de sorties et pourquoi
pas découvrir lé trésors naturels de
l'île de france la nature box propose
150 sorties activités gratuites on en
parle avec vous geoffroy backs de
keating bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet de l'agencé des
espaces verts d'île de france qui
propose cette nature box alors quels
sont les objectifs pourquoi l'a proposé
cette nature boxeur lagence des espaces
verts c'est un établissement public qui
a pour objectif d'aménager et de
protéger les espaces naturels de la
région
alors on a évidemment fait on fait tout
ce travail pour accueillir du public
pour sensibiliser les gens à la
protection de l'environnement c'est
pourquoi on a lancé la nature box donc
la nature boxe c'est un petit clin
d'oeil aux smart box qui ont fleuri ces
dernières années alors qu'il se présente
sous la forme de ce livre est qu'on peut
retrouver également en ligne en ligne
tout à fait donc l'objectif c'est de
proposer 150 animations nature pour tous
les franciliens entièrement gratuite
donc effectivement vous pouvez retrouver
sur le site www points à lever cyril de
français préfèrent et dans les offices
de tourisme et les communes ou les
animations se déroulent or l'idée c'est
aussi de montrer que l'ile-de-france au
delà de son caractère urbain c'est aussi
une région
qui est composée à 75 % d'espacés
naturels c'est ça c'est aussi l'objectif
actuellement c on pense souvent à l'île
de france comme une région très urbaine
alors qu'en fait 75 % de la région est
composée d' espaces naturels dont 25%
des espaces boisés et 50% des terres
agricoles
donc on a notamment dans les yvelines
des zones comme la forêt régionale de
ronnie la réserve naturelle de
la butte de marsan val de aussi partie
naturels régionaux parc naturel du vexin
au nord est de la haute vallée de
chevreuse au sud va les suivre donc vous
avez aussi la forêt de port royal des
champs qui est un domaine régional qui
appartient à l'agencé des espaces verts
où les gens pourront se promener et
avoir une très riche biodiversité donc
c'est excellent terrain de jeu en somme
pour découvrir la nature tout à fait en
fait les 150 animations sont destinés
aux familles aux enfants à partir de 3
ans vous avez nombreuses animations avec
des animateurs spécialisés ou passionnés
qui vont vous faire découvrir la
biodiversité les les secrets un peu d
espaces naturels régionaux alors dans
les yvelines vous en parliez il ya des
activités qui vont être proposées on
voit la carte s'affiche et des activités
au nord mais aussi dans la partie sud
des yvelines c'est ça oui vous avez à la
fois sur la partie le plateau de saclay
plus tôt des zones sur des terres
agricoles
vous avez comme je les dis non la forêt
de ronnie dans le nord-ouest
vous avez également à la rose lions vous
avez l'habitude de mars un val et donc
toutes ces zones là vous avez un certain
nombre d'activités comme oui c'est vrai
les types d'activités comme vous voulez
faire aussi bien des balades à dos d'âne
de l'initiation a dû geocaching donc
c'est à dire de la recherche de trésors
cachés par par gps vous avez de
l'observation d'oiseaux migrateurs des
enseignes des papillons de nuit etc
donc c'est des activités à faire depuis
mars et jusqu'à jusqu'à descendre
jusqu'à l'année de mars à décembre les
vacances et le week-end c'est important
de les proposer gratuitement sur cd et
des versions gratuites c'est toute la
démarche pour qu'on en a qui est de
proposer des animations gratuites parce
que nous sommes
le service public est tout ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de sensibiliser ces
gens-là sensibiliser les franciliens à
la protection de l'environnement au
fonctionnement la biodiversité de la
faune et de la flore pour mieux les
protéger
est ce que il faut s'inscrire
obligatoirement pour participer à ces
animations
oui tout à fait vous pouvez vous
inscrire sur le site que j'ai énoncé un
mois avant chaque date d'accord très
bien et on je leur précise on peut
retrouver donc se livrer soit en mairie
dans les îles de loisirs également et
vous retrouvez toute la liste les
accusent de terrorisme
office de tourisme également et toute la
liste également en ligne sur le site
internet de l'agencé des espaces verts
et d'île de france merci geoffroy vague
de critiques pour mettre bas c'est sur
ce plateau directeur de cabinet de cette
agence ait des espaces verts et d'île de
france
le sport et le cyclisme la 28ème édition
de la jean racine était organisé ce week
end au départ de saint rémy les
chevreuse plus de cinq mille sportifs
ont bravé le froid cette année pour
participer à cette course cyclotouriste
à travers les yvelines au programme neuf
parcours vtt de 10 à 120 km et trois
tracés route de 40 à 120 km et des
parcours pour les enfants étaient
également organisés on écoute les
réactions tout de suite au micro de
michael et demi d'euros a toujours à
jean racine c'est son organisation elle
est unique c'est une association une
collectivité qui organise un événement
convivial avant tout c'est pas un
événement organisé par l'entreprise qui
cherche à faire du bénéfice et non c'est
un événement qui organisait pour faire
plaisir faire du vélo et mettre les gens
au sport ça participe au rayonnement de
notre ville au rayonnement de notre
territoire la vallée de chevreuse et je
pense que tous les participants de la
région de la région ile-de-france mais
même au delà maintenant et bien au delà
rencontrer des bretons hier dès les gens
de toutes les régions de france cette
fête du vélo francilien va devenir une
fête de la fête du vélo national je
pense très vite
[Musique]
michael et me d'euros qui a signé ses
interviews de l'agent racines et qui est
avec moi en plateau bonsoir michael un
sérieux ring vous retrouvez comme chaque
lundi pour les résultats sport du week
end il y avait de beaux matchs 1
d'ailleurs dans les yvelines
alors on va parler d'un sport dont on ne
parle pas souvent c'est le roller hockey
comme du roller hockey oui c'est
exactement ça c'est du hockey mais avec
des rollers à la place des patins et on
a une très bonne équipe dans les
yvelines les chocs ce d'elancourt et
disputée ce week-end leur dernier match
de la saison 2 et n 4 les encours
tournante assurée à domicile après avoir
mené a été menée avoir mené par don de 1
à la pause
il s'impose finalement 11 à 4 le
deuxième plus gros score de la saison
pour les locaux on écoute les réactions
deuxième mi temps voilà dès qu'on a
commencé à jouer ça allait mieux quoi le
score reflète le but c'était de mettre
au maximum se faire plaisir parce qu'il
ya deux de nos joueurs qui s'en vont
quand même dans d'autres clubs pour
évoluer à plus haut niveau mais donc le
but c'était de se faire plaisir entre
nous et marquer le maximum de buts à
elancourt times cette saison en milieu
de tableau à la 5e place de la poule sur
huit équipes engagées
on va prendre maintenant la direction
michael de clairefontaine est forcément
parler de football
car voilà une journée exceptionnelle
pour 1600 enfants les jeunes
footballeurs âgés de 10 à 12 ans en plus
jouer ce samedi 13 avril sur les
terrains d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine à l'occasion de
la danone nations cup leurs coupes du
monde à eux il y avait notamment des
équipes locales comme trappe encore vu
en cours en écoute les réactions au
micro de patrick jacques de dixmude
terre c'est exceptionnel ce qu'a déjà
l'année dernière au poète
on n'est pas venu et s'anime si tu as
bien d'être là qu'on perde on regagne au
moins fait plaisir jouer à
clairefontaine
un endroit qui est normalement réservé
uniquement aux à l'élite
les pions toutes les équipes de france
c'est une expérience unique dont elles
vont se rappeler je pense le toute leur
vie après cette journée aucune équipe
lilloise n'est parvenue à se qualifier
pour la grande finale nationale qui se
disputera le 22 juin prochain à paris
merci michael ces résultats et bien
d'autres choses encore dans votre
émission le 7-8 sport c'est à retrouver
dans quelques instants après ce journal
avant de vous laisser je vous rappelle
cette information nous l'avons appris
aujourd'hui
marie-christine le tarnec démissionne de
son mandat de maire à guyancourt l'élu
siégeait à la tête du conseil municipal
depuis novembre 2016 suite à la
démission à l'époque de l'édile en place
françois de ligné il s'agissait de son
premier mandat à guyancourt et pour
assurer l'intérim en attendant à une
nouvelle élection au sein du conseil
municipal c'est françois morton le
premier adjoint qui assurera cet intérim
marie-christine le tarnec elle garde son
siège au sein du conseil municipal est
également de vice présidente de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines est la fin de ce journal le
replay et les reportages à retrouver
bien sûr sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]